[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend über 200 Familien
in Israel bangen noch immer um ihre
Kinder Töchter Schwestern Söhne
Großväter Babys seit Samstag vor zwei
Wochen werden sie vermutlich als Geiseln
von Hamas Terroristen in Gaza
festgehalten die Angehörigen klagen dass
sie zu wenig Informationen von Armee und
Regierung bekommen manche durchsuchten
selbst stundenlang die Social Media
Kanäle der Hamas und fanden dort
schreckliche Gewissheit der israelische
Regisseur Ari Vollmann beschloss zu
handeln und gründete das Projekt bring
them home now bringt sie jetzt nach
Hause sein Team führte Interviews mit
den noch immer geschockten Familien der
Verschleppten chr Lele
berichtet wir sind die Eltern von inen
die nach Gaza entführt wurde ich wusste
sie ging zu einer Party natürlich wusste
ich nicht dass sie im Süden war ich
konnte den Zusammenhang erst herstellen
nachdem wir es im Fernsehen gesehen
haben dann so gegen 12 Uhr FF ich
faceseite und ich ininerory
der in die Kamera lächelt und irgendwas
auf Arabisch sagt in dem Moment breche
ich
zusammen sie unterrichtete 20 Jahre lang
in der Grundschule ich bin sicher wenn
es dort Kinder in der Nähe gibt sie ih
Kekse backt ihn zu trinken gibt und sich
um sie kümmert denn das war
sie bringt
siechuse ale stellvertretend für die
über 200 geielopfer erzählt von
Angehörigen zusammengestellt von
israelischen Filmemachern keine
Staatspropaganda eine private Initiative
von Regisseurinnen wie rövenie mit
Geschichten die einfach nicht vergessen
werden können und
seollen diese Leute haben für lange Zeit
nach dem 7 Oktober kaum Aufmerksamkeit
von unserer Regierung bekommen unsere
Aktion ist zivilgesellschaftlich gemeint
als engagierte
Bürger es sind Menschen wie du und ich
mitten aus dem Leben gerissen erzielen
die Filme mache Kinder Töchter und Söhne
Eltern hochbetagte die älteste ist 84
Jahre alt alle Geschichten haben eines
gemeinsam es ist ein Anruf oder eine
Nachricht die alles verändert eine
geliebte Person ist verschleppt
worden ich denke die wichtigste Sache
ist unsere Botschaft die geiselfrage von
der der Militäroperation zu trennen wir
wollen immer wieder an das ungelöste
geiselproblem
erinnern ich denke das Zeitfenster geht
bald zu um noch die Chance zu haben sie
zurückzuholen volman ist einer der
renommiertesten Regisseure Israels in
seinem Drama Wals with bir beschreibt er
das nahostdilemma von Krieg und Gewalt
jetzt setzt sich Vollmann mit etwa 50
Filmkollegen für das Schicksal der
Geiseln ein
ich hoffe wirklich dass dies nicht unser
11 September
ist ich hoffe das ist ein wegruf für die
vernünftigen sekularen und rationalen
Menschen dieser Region die Sache wieder
unter Kontrolle zu bringen und sie nicht
den religiösen verrückten Fanatikern zu
überlassen auf beiden
[Musik]
Seiten hiermit wende ich mich an die
israelische an die deutsche und alle
Regierungen der ganzen Welt gebt mir
meine Schwester
zurück es kommt nicht oft vor dass der
Bundespräsident samt Regierung
Opposition Kirchen und Verbänden zu
einer Demonstration aufruft die
Kundgebung sollte ein Zeichen sein ein
langersehntes Zeichen dafür dass
Deutschland nicht nur in Worten sondern
ganz konkret auf zwei Beinen und zu
Tausenden an der Seite Israels steht
nach dem Motto nie wieder ist jetzt der
Bundeskanzler war nicht dabei er
eröffnete am Morgen in Dessau den ersten
Neubau einer Synagoge in Deutschland
seit dem Holocaust auch das ein Zeichen
Stefan Merseburger berichtet aus
Berlin mindestens 10 000 sind gekommen
sie wollen Solidarität zeigen mit Israel
und ein Zeichen setzen gegen den
brutalen Terror der hammas auch der Hass
auf Juden in Deutschland besorgt sie wir
sind aus Hamburg gekommen also meine
Freundin und ich weil ich das
erschreckend finde in welcher Art und
Weise ein Antisemitismus hier auf einmal
zum Vorschein kommt weltweit aber auch
hier bei uns in Deutschland wenn
Menschen hier nicht auf der Straße
spazieren gehen können und sich nicht
trauen können eine Kipper zu tragen wo
sind wir denn da gelandet also und das
ist ja nicht erst seit
heute also das
ist furchtbar diese barbarischen
abschlachtungen die geschehen sind die
kann man nicht gut heißen also ganz
grausam da fehlen auch die
Worte ein breites Bündnis aus Parteien
Zivilgesellschaft Kirchen und
Gewerkschaften hatte zur Kundgebung
aufgerufen jüdisches Leben zu schützen
auch das ist unsere besondere
Verantwortung unser Auftrag aus der
Geschichte ist eingeschrieben in das
Fundament auf dem unsere Demokratie
gebaut ist der Schutz jüdischen Lebens
ist Staatsaufgabe aber er ist auch
Bürgerpflicht
jawohl für die Zivilisten in Gaza wurden
humanitäre Hilfe und Korridore gefordert
von den deutschen muslimischen Verbänden
war lediglich die liberale Alhambra
Gesellschaft eingeladen die muslimische
kommunit ist sehr sehr vielfältig es
gibt sehr problematische Akteure es gibt
islamistische Akteure die insbesondere
auch über die sozialen Medien die
momentane Situation propagandistisch
ausschlachten und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir die gro
moschebände die leider wieder mal
demonstriert haben dass sie keine klare
Haltung
haben wo sind unsere Eltern unsere
Brüder unsere Schwestern sie fragen nach
den entführten Ronnie Romans Schwester
ist Geisel der Hammers und hat heute
Geburtstag noch gibt es Hoffnung für die
verschleppten aber sicher ist auch eine
Eskalation des Krieges steht
bevor wenn die Bodenoffensive beginnen
wird müssen all diejenigen die sich
heute solidarisch zeigen auch
solidarisch bleiben Kerzen am Bebelplatz
um der Geiseln und der Getöteten
Israelis zu gedenken es war ein Tag der
Verbundenheit der Krieg wird diese
Verbundenheit noch auf harte Proben
Stellen der Westen also versucht Israel
zu unterstützen moralisch und auch ganz
konkret die USA kündigten heute an ihre
militärische Präsenz im Nahen Osten zu
verstärken nach zwei Flugzeugträgern
soll jetzt auch eine Raketenabwehrsystem
ein Raketenabwehrsysteme und Patriot
Raketen in der Region stationiert werden
die Botschaft an die libanesische
Hisbollah und den Iran ist simpel mischt
euch nicht ein unterdessen gab es
weitere militärische Scharmützel im
Norden Israels an der Grenze zum Libanon
und auch im Westjordanland wächst die
Spannung l walpott berichtet aus
Israel israel hat am Wochenende seine
Luftangriffe auf Ziele im Gazastreifen
weiter verstärkt mehrere Gebäude wurden
dabei getroffen nach palästinensischen
Angaben sind in den letzten zwei Wochen
mehr als 4000 Bewohner ums Leben
gekommen Israels Armee erklärte sie
nehmen nur hamasstellungen unter
Beschuss dutzende Terroristen wurden
getötet darunter auch ein befeh
der ham
raketeneinheit Israels Armee rief erneut
alle Bewohner aus Gaza Stadt auf sich in
den Süden des Gebietes in Sicherheit zu
bringen die Versorgung der vielen
Verwundeten in den Krankenhäusern wird
zunehmend schwierig daneben Medikamenten
auch Treibstoff für die Generatoren
fehlt im Süden des gasastreifens
versuchen Flüchtlinge so gut es geht
sich in der Not zu organisieren wie
diese Mutter mit fünf
Kindern seit heute früh wollte ich
eigentlich Brot backen für die Kinder
aber wir mussten erstmal lange nach Mehl
suchen es gibt fast nichts mehr es ist
traurig überall Zerstörung überall
Krieg Hilfslieferungen rollten auch
heute wieder aus Ägypten Richtung Gaza
konnten aber zunächst nicht entladen
werden weil eine israelische Granate nah
des Grenzübergangs einschlug Israels
Armee sprach von einem bedauerlichen
versehen am Abend sollen die 17
Lastwagen doch noch entladen werden aus
der Luft griff die Armee heute auch eine
Moschee im Flüchtlingslager Genin im
Westjordanland an dort habe sich ein
unterirdischer terrorkomplex von Hamas
und des Islamischen Jihad Befunden heißt
es diese Mosche in Genin war ein
Versteck für Terroristen die einen
Anschlag auf israelische Bürger geplant
haben das haben wir
verhindert an der Grenze zum Libanon gab
es auch heute wieder Artillerieangriff
der libanesischen hisbolla weitere 14
israelische Dörfer wurden evakuiert
Regierungschef Netanyahu auf
Truppenbesuch warnte hiszbollah vor
einem Krieg das so Netanyahu wäre ein
schwerer
Fehler aus Tel Aviv ist uns jetzt Mosche
Zimmermann zugeschaltet er hat an der
Hebräischen Universität von Jerusalem
deutsche Geschichte gelehrt guten Abend
nach Tel
Aviv guten Abend nach Mals wir haben die
Sendung begonnen mit dem Schicksal der
Verschleppten und ihrer Familien das ist
ja für Israel ein grauenhaftes Dilemma
einerseits die über 200 Geiseln zu
befreien andererseits die Hamas
zerschlagen zu wollen und die
Zivilbevölkerung noch zu schützen was
ist eigentlich das
Wichtigste das wichtigste ist wenn man
moralisch denkt die Geiseln zu befreien
israel hat eigentlich diese Bevölkerung
neben dem Gazastreifen verraten
vergessen und es ist jetzt mindestens
die erste Aufgabe die wichtigste Aufgabe
so viele Geisel wie möglich wieder
zurück nach Hause zu holen erst dann
kommen die anderen Aufgaben dieser
Regierung ich weiß nicht ob alle meiner
Meinung sind das ist meine Meinung aber
das würde ja heißen dass die
Bodenoffensive eigentlich jetzt noch
nicht beginnen darf
oder es könnte sein dass man mit Hilfe
der Bodenoffensive geisern befreien will
das ist eine militärische frage ich kann
sie nicht beantworten aber es scheint so
zu sein dass die Befreiung zuerst kommen
muss bevor die Offensive beginnt weil
die Offensive wahrscheinlich dazu führt
dass auch Geiseln getötet
werden wie wie ist denn die Diskussion
in in Israel also klar die Angehörigen
der Geisel sind natürlich gegen den
Beginn der Bodenoffensive viele Familien
haben ja auch Söhne und Töchter in der
Armee und dennoch hören wir immer in
Meinungsumfragen dass eigentlich die
meisten Israelis sagen das ist ein Krieg
den müssen wir jetzt führen auch wenn er
blutig
wird okay die israelische Bevölkerung
ist se hitzköpfig ganz bestimmt nachdem
was am 7 Oktober passierte also der
Wunsch nach Vergeltung oder nach einer
neuen Ordnung ist besonders stark und
deswegen sind sehr viele bereit sogar
die Geiseln an zweite Stelle zu
stellen äh das ist eine Stimmung die
typisch ist für die Israelis immer
wieder wenn man angegriffen wird ist der
erste Wunsch eben nach einer
militärischen einen militärischen Schlag
das ist jetzt umso mehr so weil die
Erniedrigung und weil äh das was dort
passierte das Massaker die Leute ins
Herz trifft es scheint ja in diesem
Krieg zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern auf beiden Seiten kaum
möglich zu sein sich jeweils in die Lage
des anderen zu versetzen natürlich ist
es jetzt für Israel noch schwieriger
nach dem brutalen Angriff aber gibt es
eigentlich stimmen in ihrem Land die
auch das Leid in Gaza sehen und
kritisieren
selbverständlich gibt es solche Stimmen
die Israeli sind empfindlich genug oder
viele in Israel sind empfindlich genug
um selbverständlich sich damit zu
befassen wie das Schicksal der Armen
Palästinenser in
Gaza ist aber die Priorität legt bei den
eigenen Opfer bei den eigenen Geiseln
also das steht als allererste auf der
Tagesordnung und das andere an der
zweiten Stelle man kann auch nicht von
einer solchen Gesellschaft wie
israelische Gesellschaft erwarten dass
sie sehr viel oder viel zu viel sich um
die Leiden der Feinde kümmern weil eben
das Leid der eigenen Bevölkerung das
haben wir am 7 Oktober gesehen so groß
ist präzedentlos ist ein progrom in
Israel das ist etwas womit man sehr
schwer her leben kann angenommen es
würde gelingen in einer Bodenoffensive
die Hamas auszuschalten wie welches
Szenario sehen Sie danach für den
Gazastreifen was müsste dort
passieren was müsste passieren ist
selverständlich eine internationale
Intervention eine internationale
um dort eine neue palästinensische
Regierung zu
installieren das ist verständlich etwas
was schwer machbar ist ganz bestimmt
jetzt jetzt viel schwieriger als noch
vor 10 oder 20 oder 30 Jahren aber das
ist der Weg aus also eine israelische
Herrschaft im gaserastreifen muss man
ausschließen eine Rückkehr der Hamas
will man auch ausschließen da muss eine
andere palästinensische Regierung her
unterstützt von der internationalen
Gemeinschaft das ist die große Aufgabe
der internationalen Gemeinschaft im
Moment die internationale Gemeinschaft
die bisher zu solchen Aufgaben nicht in
der Lage war danke mche Zimmermann war
das emeritierter Professor für deutsche
Geschichte herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch nach Tel Aviv vielen
Dank das Gespräch haben wir genauso vor
einer Stunde aufgezeichnet und wir
machen hier weiter mit den Nachrichten
und mit Heinz Wolf und da geht zunächst
um Innenpolitik ja der CDU Vorsitzende
März hat sich in der Migrationsdebatte
dafür ausgesprochen die Integration
neben dem Bekenntnis zum Grundgesetz an
eine feste Zusage an das Existenzrecht
Israels zu binden wer das nicht
unterschreibe habe in Deutschland nichts
zu suchen sagte märz in der zdfsendung
Berlin direkt dass man spätestens jetzt
genauer hinschauen müsse wer da kommt
sei nicht mehr bestreitbar so März
weiter der linke kovorsitzende der
Schirdewan hat Konsequenzen angekündigt
als Reaktion auf die Pläne von Sarah
Wagenknecht morgen die Gründung eines
Vereins bekannt zu geben der der
Vorbereitung einer neuen Partei dienen
soll schördewan sagte dem ZDF es sei
klar dass die die sich an der Bildung
einer konkurrenzpartei beteiligen in der
Linkspartei nichts mehr zu suchen hätten
er verwies etwa auf die Möglichkeit
Mitgliedsrechte zu entziehen die
Mitgliedschaft
aufzuheben Deutschland sichert der
Ukraine weitere Unterstützung zu 200
Millionen Euro sollen für Bildung
Gesundheitsversorgung Trinkwasser und
den Wiederaufbau bereitgestellt werden
so entwicklungsstaatssekretär flasbad
der diese Woche in der Ukraine war bei
einem russischen Raketenangriff sind in
harkiv am Samstagabend sechs Menschen
getötet und mindestens 16 verletzt
worden melden ukrainische Behörden eine
russische Rakete habe ein
postverteilungszentrum
getroffen in Iran ist die 16-jährige
armita gerwand die nach einer
mutmaßlichen Konfrontation mit
Sittenwächtern ins Koma gefallen war
offenbar für Hirntod erklärt worden das
berichten iranische Medien
Menschenrechtsgruppen hatten Anfang
Oktober erklärt gerwand sei in der
tieraner U-Bahn bei einer
Auseinandersetzung mit Kontrolleuren
wegen
verschleierungsvorschriften verletzt
worden und ins Koma
gefallen der Gericht in Teran hat zwei
preisgekrönte JournalistInnen im
zusammen mit den landesweiten Protesten
zu mehrjährigen Gefängnisstrafen
verurteilt elahe mohammedi und nilofa
hamedi wurden Zusammenarbeit mit den USA
und Verstöße gegen die nationale
Sicherheit vorgeworfen die UNESCO hatte
beide mit dem pressefreiheitspreis
ausgezeichnet bei der Nationalratswahl
in der Schweiz zeichnet sich ein
Wahlsieg der Schweizerischen Volkspartei
ab ersten Hochrechnungen zuurfolge
bleibt die nationalkonservative SVP
stärkste Kraft mit leichten zugewinnen
auf Platz 2 folgten demnach mit
deutlichem Abstand die Sozialdemokraten
dominierendes Thema im Wahlkampf war die
Migration mit einem Erfolg der
Rechtspopulisten war gerechnet
worden noch ist nicht aufgearbeitet wie
es der Hamas gelingen konnte einen so
überraschenden und minutiös geplanten
Angriff auf Israel durchzuführen aber
eins ist klar die Hamas operiert nicht
mehr wie früher mit selbstmordattentät
und Raketen Mar Eigenbau sondern die
Terrortruppe ist inzwischen
professionell trainiert und ausgerüstet
auch zwei Wochen nach dem Beginn der
israelischen Luftschläge auf Gaza kommt
noch immer Raketenbeschuss von
Stellungen der Hamas Kamran safiarian
ist der Frage nachgegangen woher die
Geldströme der terrormiliz
kommen sie gilt als eine der reichsten
Terrorgruppen der Welt die Hamas laut US
Finanzministerium besitzt sie mindest
ens 500 Millionen
Dollar wie auf diesem propagand Video zu
sehen ist kann die Hamas auf ausgefeilte
Technik und ein riesiges Waffenarsenal
zurückgreifen doch wie kommt die Hamas
an Geld wie finanziert sie sich die
Hamas hat ja ein recht verzweigtes
Finanzsystem man darf nicht vergessen
die Hamas ist natürlich im gasstreifen
quasi die Regierung das heißt sie nimmt
dort auch Steuern ein sie erhebt auch
Zölle z.B auf Leute die nach Ägypten
fahren oder Dinge zurückbringen durch
die Tunnel auch die Hamas hat ja ein
verzweigtes
Tunnelsystem ein Tunnelsystem dass der
Hamas als Einnahmequelle dient und auch
als Einfallstor für den Schmuggel von
Geld und Gütern für die
hamasführung dieses Tunnelsystem das ist
ja geschätzt 400 km lang also so groß
wie die Londoner U-Bahn das es besteht
aus sehr rudimentären Tunneln wo nur ein
Kämpfer durch kann aber eben auch sehr
raffinierten Tunneln wo ganze Autos
transportiert werden können natürlich
auch Kämpfer Waffen und andere Güter
auch Luxusgüter und auf all das erhebt
die Hamas steuern die Hamas zapft
unterschiedlichste Geldquellen an
Spendenaufrufe über die sozialen Medien
kryptowährung und Gelder die als
Hilfsgelder getar nach Gaza gelangen
weltweit gibt es Organisationen
hilfsvereine die nach Gaza Geld schicken
auf ganz unterschiedlichen Wegen da kann
das havala System eine Rolle spielen wo
man also irgendwo in Berlin Neuköln
einzahlt und das Geld dann mit einer
Nummer oder einem Codewort in Gaza
abholen kann da spielt Bitcoin wohl
mittlerweile eine Rolle wichtig ist aber
dass wir nicht so genau wissen wie viel
Geld auf diese Weise an die Hamas
gelangt hinzu kommt Organisationen und
Staaten wie Iran die Muslimbrüder oder
Qatar gelten als Hauptsponsoren der
Hamas wieso werden die Geldströme nicht
unterbunden die Hamas ist natürlich für
uns eine Terrororganisation für Israel
sowieso aber in vielen arabischen
Ländern ist die Hamas nicht verboten ist
keine Terrororganisation das heißt sie
kann sich dort nach wie vor organisieren
sie kann eine legale Repräsentanz
aufrecht erhalten und sie kann sogar
Bankkonten haben und und Geld
transferieren und so werden wohl weiter
Gelder an die Hammers fließen und weiter
terrorfinanzieren und hier gibt's jetzt
weitere Nachrichten mit W
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
will es für Eltern künftig einfacher
machen Kinderkrankengeld in Anspruch zu
nehmen sie sollten nicht mehr am ersten
Tag an dem das Kind krank ist zum Arzt
müssen das sei unsünige Bürokratie sagte
lauterbachtebild am Sonntag der
Arztbesuch sollte nach diesem Vorschlag
erst ab dem vierten Tag notwendig werden
zur Frage wann das gelten solle sagte
Lauterbach am besten noch in dieser
wintererkältungssaison zu den beiden
Sonntagsspielen in der Fußball
buundesliga der erste fC Köln hat gegen
Borussia mönchenggladbach gewonnen 3:1
und Heidenheim hat 2:5 gegen Augsburg
verloren das Pergamonmuseum in Berlin
hatte heute zum vorerst letzten Mal
geöffnet ab morgen wird es für
umfangreiche Sanierungsarbeiten für
mehrere Jahre geschlossen bedeutende
Objekte sollen währenddessen in anderen
Berliner Museen zu sehen sein in vier
Jahren soll der Saal mit dem Pergamon
Altar wieder eröffnet werden andere
museumsteile erst im Jahr
2037 der Mann ist Optimist anders lässt
sich sein Leben nicht erklären schreiben
so sagt er ist ein optimistischer Akt
man geht davon aus dass es später jemand
liest Salmann rusti kann sich nur unter
strengsten Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
bewegen seit der iranische Ayatollah
komeni vor fast 35 Jahren zu seiner
Ermordung aufrief Grund war sein Buch
die Satanischen Verse rusti muss sich
seitdem zwar verstecken verstummte aber
nicht er schrieb weiter gegen
Extremisten von rechts und von links für
die Meinungsfreiheit ohne sich dabei je
von islamfeinden vereinnahmen zu lassen
und rusti ist ein großartiger
Schriftsteller dafür und für seine
Unbeugsamkeit bekam er heute den
Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels
peter teisen war
dabei gefeiert wird Salmann ruschti
heute in der Paulskirche als großer
Kämpfer für die Freiheit des Wortes
gegen Einschüchterung egal ob durch
Islamisten oder den Mob im
Netz die Antwort lautet wir sollten
weiterhin und mit frischem Elan das tun
was wir immer schon tun mussten
schlechte rede mit besserer Rede Kontern
auf Hass mit Liebe Antworten und nicht
die Hoffnung aufgeben dass ich die
Wahrheit selbst in einer Zeit der Lügen
durchsetzen
kann
aber immer friedlich fast wäre seine
Stimme für immer verstummt als vor 14
Monaten ein radikaler Islamist bei einer
Lesung auf ihn einsticht rusti überlebt
ganz knapp bereits 1989 hatte Ayatollah
romeni mit einer Fatwa zu Mord an rusti
aufgerufen wegen der Satanischen Verse
große Literatur für fanatische Muslime
aber eine Provokation seit Jahrzehnten
muss ich rusti vor dem Hass der hächer
in Acht nehmen auf der buchmessengala
wird rusti gefragt wie er denn
eigentlich mit dieser ständigen Angst
umgehe die Antwort typisch
rusti natürlich muss man vor bestimmten
Dingen Angst haben was man dagegen tun
kann die Angst in eine kleine Box
stecken diese Box in eine Ecke des
Zimmers stellen und dann den Tag
genießen selten dass Journalisten bei
einer Pressekonferenz Beifall klatschen
vielleicht tun sie es bei Salman rusti
weil der mit seinem Kampf für die
Freiheit des Wortes auch die ihre quasi
mitverteidigt und er beweist dass eine
der schärfsten Waffen des
Schriftstellers der Humor ist auf die
Frage ob er Angst habe durch Frankfurts
Straßen zu gehen und ob er Zeit habe mit
Schriftsteller Kollegen einen Kaffee zu
trinken antwortet
rusti ich habe eine sehr gute Zeit ich
verbringe sie ausschließlich mit
Journalisten Daniel Kehlmann als
Laudator lobt die feinen Antennen
rusties der ne weltbewegende Ereignisse
lange voraus und verwandel sie in seinen
Romanen große Kunst der vielleicht
wichtigste Verteidiger der Freiheit von
Kunst und Rede in unserer Zeit vor allem
aber ein Weiser neugieriger heiterer und
gütiger Mensch und somit der würdigste
Träger den es für diese Auszeichnung die
ja als Friedenspreis ausdrücklich nicht
nur künstlerische sondern auch
humanistische Größe würdigt überhaupt
hätte geben
können ein großer Autor eine beugsame
Stimme nach den Jahrzehnten des Hasses
und der Morddrohungen gegen ihn ist es
ein kleines Wunder dass Salman rusti den
Friedenspreis heute entgegennehmen
konnte und zum Schluss schauen wir noch
auf das was uns die nächste Woche bringt
der heute journal Ausblick von Ralf
[Musik]
panitck es werden schwierige und lange
Gespräche erwartet wenn am Donnerstag
die ländertarifverhandlungen beginnen
Gewerkschaften fordern für die rund 1,2
Millionen Beschäftigten 10,5% mehr Lohn
mindestens aber 500 € monatlich die
Länder halten dies angesichts
lehrerkassen für nicht
finanzierbar am Donnerstag wird auch das
zweitägige Treffen der EU
Regierungschefs beginnen zentrales Thema
des Gipfels in Brüssel der nostkonflikt
ganz oben auf der Tagesordnung aber auch
die Probleme mit illegaler Einwanderung
beim letzten Gipfel konnte keine
gemeinsame Linie in der Migrationsfrage
gefunden
werden ein Land zwischen Aufbruch und
tiefer Krise die Türkei am Sonntag wird
sie 100 Jahre alt am 29 oktober
1923 hatte Präsident Atter Türk die
Republik ausgerufen als Nachfolger des
Osmanischen Reiches am Jubiläumstag wird
im ganzen Land gefeiert mit Konzerten
Feuerwerk und ganz viel
Patos die Uhr tickt in der Nacht zum
Sonntag beginnt die Winterzeit am
letzten Sonntag im Oktober wird die Uhr
wieder einmal ein Stunde zurückgestellt
in Deutschland wie auch den meisten
europäischen Ländern dann ist die eine
Nacht eine Stunde
länger und jetzt erst noch mal kurz zum
Beginn der neuen Woche da wird das
Wetter so morgen ist es nach
Nebelauflösung im Nord und Südosten
länger sonnig von Südwesten breiten sich
dichte Wolken aus am Nachmittag mit
Regen bei 12 bis 18° in den nächsten
Tagen bleibt der Himmel meist grau es
wird windig und regnerisch bei 11 bis
18° das war's von uns hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit der schwedischen Krimiserie
Detective number 24 und um 025 Uhr
gibt's dann die nächste heute Express
wir wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start in
die neue Woche in der erwarten Sie hier
dunia Hayali und gundol Gause
[Musik]
tschüss